the thought pyramid arts center collects
preserves and studies the contemporary
art of africa
dill humphrey is listed among the 50
most influential artists in africa the
junk man as he calls himself is
preoccupied with the explosive growth of
african cities
and i don't just make art i use junk to
cook soup i can use look at the junk of
the people
and
find out their lifestyle
the state of their financial well-being
their
thinking patterns their world views
all in their junk
in their work dill humphrey and his
colleagues recycle and transform old
clothing and other debris found on the
streets of several african cities
they then create sculptures
installations and performances in which
they aim to reflect the disenfranchised
situation of many african people
dill humphrey and his fellow artists
have exhibited more than 20 works in the
art center in abuja
art lovers here can admire old cement
bags
magazines
empty cans
and other waste material
the campaigns we'll do we'll talk about
the environment
how to manage our waste properly so for
me i've seen a place where the waste is
being converted to act something very
meaningful it makes a whole lot of sense
to the cost of sustainability makes a
whole lot of sense at the cost of
climate change because of managing the
environment
most of the pieces shown at the art
center in abuja are the result of a
two-week training period coordinated by
dill humphrey
the junk man of africa works as a
sculptor performance artist and painter
at the reception he taught people about
the importance of the environment and
waste management when you want to see
the truth
you go to the ugly side of human beings
life itself
is within
themselves they are drunk used and
disused
some of the other artists who had their
artworks on display explain the concept
behind their pieces and the skills
they're taking beyond these walls
we're trying to
make a second meaning
of these wastes
instead of turning them around
we can use them to create something
something very important
something that'll have a permanent life
contemporary african art is increasingly
attracting the attention of global
investors and becoming ever more
valuable for the junk man of africa and
his colleagues it's an opportunity to
embed environmental protection deeper
into the conscience of society